hi guys my name's Tamara chambers and
this is Tara's never seen today I am
watching watership down full disclosure
actually I've already seen the movie
they've already filmed this reaction to
it
but I was really sick and I put on a
shirt that just didn't work and it would
have been distracting for reasons so I
like was walking back the footage and I
was like oh my god I have to redo this
don't I though I don't think people are
going to be very excited about my
opinion of watership down and I was
expecting emerald like almost like a war
movie maybe or like I got Waterworld in
my head obviously water water but I
wasn't expecting it to be animated and
the picture that I saw online was like
an animated bunny and I kept Doug is
this the water shut down you were
talking about he said yeah but don't let
the bunny fool you so I went into this
thinking that it was going to be really
traumatizing
and really gory and really intense just
because it had been built up so we'll
see do they have a CD yet guys be losing
the food we're going to play the intro
and then I'll have Zenith
Potter has never seen okay here's my
thing it's my fault because I didn't see
this movie what I should have I should
have seen as a kid been traumatized by
it and then lived to tell the tale but
no I had to wait until I was 26 years
old to see it and so I've heard things
about it it's been built up in my mind
so it didn't deliver because I built it
up too much the height was too much too
much hyped camera - I think the
animation was gorgeous and I I think the
story was boring as I'm stressed out by
these bunny rabbits for sure stressed
for their lives but it's like man I
might only hate to worry about it I want
to be stressing about these bunnies the
voice acting was odd in a way that I
like I kind of liked the weirdness of it
just like these puns are grounded as
hell these are some adult as bunnies I
don't know I didn't cry I thought there
was some trippy part like the whole
burying sequence where they're getting
buried alive best horrifying and the
animation turns into like a different
style unwelcome it's really cool I like
how there's different animation in the
beginning talking about the god that's
me um but honestly and watching through
the movie I was so bored everything took
so long suggest we get it you're moving
from one burrow to the other burrow we
get it bunny move on and I be only one
feel that it feel like I might be the
only one who feels that I don't know
y'all I read your production opening
animation so this is just going to be
able to be about rabbits in their
struggle cool and I wrote that down
because expecting it to get like crazy a
step and not just be about their
struggle and I was going
like not at all but it was just a strata
struggle but I don't know what I was
expecting but I think that they were
going to like chop each other's heads
off I don't know what was I expecting
what I don't know I don't fit up so much
it's just definitely the most
interesting and engaging part and like
the one that lived up to the hype the
most is is the sequence of them being
buried alive
and you see all the little rabbits faces
and it's really sad and never loved
rabbits I want to pet rat so bear
excellent storytelling through that you
see these rabbits living their life and
this wasn't that you didn't see like the
rabbits going through that it was more
stylized which i think is cool kind of
broke out of the animation stop for a
moment okay then next is my favorite
character who is the bird
I love the bird the birds at the saving
grace of this film what the hell is that
Birds accent I don't it is it Mexican is
it it was a fan thing what who are you
where are you from
she says the funniest when I fly
stand back stand back
damn it I saw okay but do they go on
this whole journey and the only female
that was with them gets eaten by an owl
that's their like spy will figure it out
and so they get to their new Warren
after like all this struggle and you
know the elements are against them and
they're like ah but we can't mate that's
a problem and so they have to go back
and get mates and then then then there's
this whole like bunny squad then they're
just like evil bunnies and they're like
slave owners and slave drivers and just
like calm down like you
god you're complicating things so you're
a bunny just live like a bunny go eat
some carrots man and shell out big wigs
one of the bunnies like joins them and
they wrote big wood joins the Ocelot the
icing flops the ice
whatever they've got really weird name
we're trying to help them escape and
then he gets into a fight with the
leader of the the mean Nazi bunnies and
that's pretty intense slept scratching
and blood happening there animation is
really interesting and you start
watching the movie me like okay
everything's normal here but just like a
weird thing really goes like has a weird
unsettled unsettling feeling to it it
will probably weird so it's odd that
they get away and they have made snow
and they've saved these bunnies and
they're in their new warren burrow and
then at the end who died hazel hazel
dies whose fibers friends and first of
all back up I'd love that fiber is this
like little spiritual bun-bun who could
just like tell the future and very like
into into things happening good on your
fiber you're more emotionally available
with I am hazel is fibers friends and
hazel passes away at the end of this
movie and it's a cool style icing where
they bring this bunny Grim Reaper to
come and grab him so the bunny Grim
Reaper is just for bunnies I heard a
busiest Grim Reaper ever slaughtered but
I think this is the first movie if four
cameras never seen that I'm just like
not into in a way like I appreciate like
you did cool like whatever it was
worth Dark Crystal but I think I enjoyed
it more this was just like I really
missed the mark on this I really missed
the time when I was supposed to see this
I think and it probably just shows like
what a terrible content of you are I am
like that I couldn't get much out of it
well I feel like I'm the only one who
feels this way about this movie I'm a
little nervous
everyone's being read these predictions
though
we'll see that all right fam last one
send me those watership down predictions
hashtag have favors ever seen bunny
emoji school crossroads emoji and then a
lovely picture of me looking scared
bunny ears on so and says Oh buddy Tim
you'll cry over the bunnies and not want
to sleep the following night I didn't
cry everyone thinks I'm going to cry
holy when did rabbits get so
violent
feeling they're violent they're cool
creatures crazy cause they live in the
wild like I feel like it's a pretty
accurate description of bunnies you're
going to be fat and want to hug your cat
that's true you'll understand the public
outcry when the BBC showed it on Easter
Sunday during kids TV that does seem
dumb that seems like something that like
goes under the radar as a kid you watch
the thing you're like huh scary that was
not good I didn't I didn't enjoy that
you grow up and you're like that was one
of those things I probably showed him
the scene I just realized something when
I was a child my brother and I had a pet
rabbit and my brother put his hand in
the cage and got it stuck and the rabbit
leg not on his thumb and like it almost
he lost his thumb we just like rush to
the hospital
maybe I'm suppressing a lot of anger
towards rabbit maybe just maybe we just
figured it out that I've heard him say
that plague dog is sadder than this
maybe I would like plague dog more well
very depressing the best I can say about
this film is Christ this movie was just
weird and bloody that's a good way to
put it is depressing but not cry
depressing just like look this is a
bummer
laugh to quote Doug sob I think everyone
loved this movie except for me I have to
be honest I'm feeling a little liberated
that I have a movie that I don't enjoy
that everyone else enjoys that's cool
cuz I like everything I'm always like it
was so good
I didn't like this that much whatever
what are you gonna do didn't cry I feel
like a heartless being Miami so
heartless kind of process I have to go
hard next week hopefully I'll be doing a
reaction video to death note 1 & 2 the
movies I see you wanna come say hi
he's napping he does not want to come
say hi
he's looking at me like no we all know
the true star of the show is okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you